اكثر من 70 يوما لا يزال القتال مستمرا في
قطاع غزه على اكثر من محور مع دخول هذه
العمليه البريه مرحله جديده او مراحل
جديده مع كل يوم تتوغل فيه القوات
الاسرائيليه بطبيعه الحال في المناطق
الشماليه من قطاع غزه والمناطق الجنوبيه
المناطق الشماليه نتحدث عن مدينه غزه
ومحيطها وايضا مناطق شمال غزه جبالي وبيت
لاهيه وبيت حنون وايضا خان يونس مع
استمرار قصف المقاومه الفلسطينيه للاهداف
داخل منطقه غلاف غ ز بعمق حوالي اربعه الى
خه كيلومترات في مجمعات المستوطنات التي
نعرفها جميعا اشكول وشعر هنيغف واشكو اذا
ما دخلنا الى مناطق التوغل الاسرائيلي
ونتحدث بطبيعه الحال عن المنطقه الشمال
المنطقه الجنوبيه المنطقه الجنوبيه تتوغل
فيها الولايات العسكريه الاسرائيليه من
المنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه ل خانيونس والم
المنطقه الشرقيه من المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه ودخلت ايضا المنطقه الغربيه
والمنطقه الشماليه الغربيه هذا هو شكل
التوغل الاسرائيلي ل مناطق في خان يونس
هذه الدائره التي تشكلها التوغ
الاسرائيليه في خان يونس تحكم الق تحكم
السيطره تحكم المحاصره مدينه خانيونس ووسط
مدينه خانيونس بهذه الطريقه في هجوم مكثف
للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه وكن في
المقابل هناك تصريحات مهمه ولافته للنظر
من كتاب القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه عن
تصدي لهذه الاليات متوغل وضربها في اكثر
من موقع واكثر من مناسبه وتحديدا تركز
الكتائب في بياناتها على المناطق الشماليه
من خانيونس والشماليه الشرقيه والمناطق
الشرقيه عندما نتحدث عن المناطق الشرقيه
فنحن نتحدث عن مناطق عبسان وبن سهيلا
الشماليه الشرقيه نتحدث عن الزنه وصولا
الى القراره ونتحدث ايضا عن المناطق
الشماليه الغربيه مدينه حمد او ما بات
يعرف بمحرر جوش قطيف في المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه اذا معارك عنيفه تخوضها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في خانيونس لكن اذا ما انتقلنا
الى المنطقه الشماليه والتي تحمل عاده
التطورات الابرز والاهم ولا تزال محاور ال
القتال حتى هذه اللحظه ثابته في الشجاعيه
في مخيم جباليا وفي منطقه الشيخ رضوان في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
وفي منطقه بيت لاهيه التي تغيب وتحضر في
واجهه الاحداث والاخبار المتوارث القوات
الاسرائيليه قوات الاحتلال تحاول السيطره
على الشجاعيه والتوغل في الشجاعيه اذا ما
دخلنا الى الشجاعيه في هذه الخريطه
فالقوات الاسرائيليه تحاول التوغل في
الشجاعيه بهذا الشكل من الجهه الجنوبيه
الغربيه ومن الجهه الش الشرقيه من الجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه سعيا منها للوصول الى
قلب مدينه غزه هذه التي نراها في وسط
الدائره هي قلب مدينه غزه والبلده القديمه
من مدينه غزه وهنا تخوض المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اشتباكات عنيفه مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول التوغل في
الشجاعيه ولكن الشجاعيه لا تزال تضرب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
اليوم والمتعلق بالنفق الذي تم اكتشافه في
هذه المنطقه المنطقه الشماليه من مدينه
غزه وتحديدا نتحدث عن معبر ايرز هذا هو
معبر ايرز هذه مستوطنه ايرز او نقطه
عسكريه لايرز وهذا معبر ايرز وهذا هو شارع
صلاح الدين الذي يربط بين مناطق شمال قطاع
غزه وجنوبها ومنه الى الداخل عبر معبر
ايرز يتم دخول الفلسطينيين الى مناطق داخل
الخط الاخضر او المناطق الاسرائيليه داخل
الخط الاخضر هذه الدائره هي معبر ايرز
يقول قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اليوم انها
اكتشفت نفقا في هذه المنطقه وهو نفق يمتد
على طول 4 ك م تقريبا من عند معبر ايرز
وصولا الى المناطق الغربيه من منطقه بيت
حنون اذا ما رسمنا خريطه افتراضيه لهذا
النفق فنحن نتحدث عن هذا الشكل اذا وفقا
روايه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهذه هي
المسافه التي نت تحدث عنها حوالي 4 كيلو
كما ذكرت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انها
اكتشفت هذا النفق بعمق 50 متر تحت الارض
وهو نفق ضخم للغايه وفق الصور التي نشرتها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه المنطقه
ولكن هذا النفق هو واحد من مجموعه كبيره
جدا من الانفاق ومئات الامتار من الانفاق
وفق الروايات ووفق تقارير وتحقيقات صحفيه
واعلاميه تقول قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ان هذا النفق في هذه المنطقه هو اكتشاف
مهم للغايه ووفق الصور التي شاهدناها فان
هذا النق فق ضخم للغايه ويمكن دخول سيارات
وعربات داخله في هذه المنطقه هذا يعني ان
المناطق الحدوديه لقطاع غزه اذا ما عدنا
الى كل القطاع هذا يعني المناطق الحدوديه
لقطاع غزه التي تمتد بهذا الشكل هي مناطق
كلها معرضه لان تكون باتجاهها انفاق قد
تكون قد اخترقت الحدود باتجاه الاراضي
داخل الخط الاخضر وبالاضافه الى الانفاق
الكثير والكثيفه للغايه في هذه المنطقه في
مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه